hey everybody how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
so a lot of y'all noticed in my recent
videos that i got a new keyboard
and you're like where you go why haven't
you talked about it yet do you like it
what do you like about it what do you
not like about it
so today we're gonna talk about it i've
made like a few
other keyboard videos before like best
keyboard for programmers
all of my desk setup videos where i talk
about keyboards so
if you're new here because you're also
part of the keyboard community hello
welcome my name is miyuko
if you like this video at the end please
consider subscribing
okay so let's talk about it this is the
hhkb
the happy hacking keyboard i have the
professional hybrid
type s so before we dive into like the
specs or like the review part of the
video
i want to talk about what's important to
me in a keyboard and also why i chose to
try out this one
as far as keyboards go for me i'm like
pretty pragmatic
i need something that like works well is
super duper reliable
and it's just kind of like fun to type
on so there's really like three main
like things that i'm looking for in a
keyboard
comfort usability and delight which
that's very similar to like how i
view any product out in the world
whether it's like an ios app or a
keyboard or like
i don't know a new wooden spoon or
something like that and i was in the
market for a new keyboard because i
wanted to try a new one
and i have been recommended the hhkb by
many friends
but it wasn't until i saw a video by a
japanese youtube channel called tobarugu
that i kind of just went for it in the
video he reviews his hhkb
and he talks so passionately about it
that i was like okay
i gotta try this one and specifically i
really wanted
a mechanical bluetooth keyboard that was
kind of like
white ish and had decent build quality
and surprisingly when you look for those
specific requirements it's actually kind
of hard to find like a really good
keyboard
and anywhere i looked when i searched
those terms they were like dude
just get an hhkb so yes i went for it i
bought this keyboard
i bought it in may it's july now so i've
been testing it for
about two months and i feel like i can
finally like give it a proper review
so let's talk about the specs of this
thing so the hhkb comes in three types
the pro hybrid type s the pro hybrid and
the pro classic
i bought the top of the line
professional hybrid type s version
because
i wanted to try out like the best of
this version of it
i bought it with my own money i wasn't
sent this or anything like that
fujitsu is the company that makes this
and it's made in japan
the switches are topra electrostatic
capacitive silent key switches they're
pretty squishy and it comes in four
color ways you can get it either in
white or black and then you can also get
the blank key caps or the printed ones
as you can see in mine i got the white
blank keycaps which we'll talk about
whether that was a good idea in a little
bit
you can pair up to four different
bluetooth devices and you can also plug
in using a usb-c cord right here
it runs on two double-a batteries and it
boasts three months of battery life
and so this model itself when i bought
it it was 337 us dollars
okay so now that that's done the specs
are done the objectivity is out the
window
now let's bring in the subjectivity and
my opinions about this thing
i remember there's three different
buckets comfort usability and delight so
i'm going to talk about this keyboard in
those three
different ways so the first is comfort i
spend
hours and hours and hours on this thing
every single day and so it's really
important to me to have a very
comfortable keyboard
and when it comes to comfort i think the
topper switches actually are very very
comfortable to type on
prior to this i was using the kikron k2
and that uses cherry mx browns
and i've also typed on cherry mx blues i
also
have used like the logitech mx keys that
are more of the chiclet keys and all
mechanical
out of all of those i think the topper
switches are definitely the most
comfortable like i don't have to slam
the keys or anything at all
and it's just very just like seamless
the best way that i can describe them is
that they're just like very
squishy so it feels like it like pads my
fingers a little bit when i type
not that it makes like a huge difference
like i don't necessarily see
like a difference in my finger fatigue
at the end of the day or anything like
that
but it is just like more comfortable
to type on i will include a sound test
at the end when we're going over the
delight section because then i think
you'll get a sense of like how squishy
it actually is
so hhkb does make a wrist rest but i
didn't love the look of them so i didn't
buy them so i've been using this without
a wrist
rest and i gotta say it's pretty tall as
a keyboard and so i kind of wish
i had a wrist rest so i probably will be
getting one but all in all that hasn't
really caused like
any problems i would say like my wrist
doesn't hurt anymore
because of this one you can also tilt
the keyboard
up more with the little things on the
back but i just don't see a need for
that so they're always closed for me
all in all i think it's a very
comfortable keyboard it's a nice sized
one for my hands too especially because
my hands
are pretty small and so i can reach all
the keys using my two hands which is
really nice so i don't have to travel
very far
to get to what i need so that's comfort
i would say it's like
9 out of 10 8 out of 10 on comfort like
pretty dang comfortable i don't know
what a 10 out of 10 comfort keyboard
would look like
and i feel like you can always strive
for more so i'm going to land it in kind
of like
it's an a in comfort the next is
usability and i have a lot to say about
the usability of this keyboard
first of which which is like the most
talked about part about the hhkb
is the layout so layout on this keyboard
is a little abnormal
compared to like your standard keyboard
mostly
in that it doesn't have as many keys on
the bottom row right here
and so because there isn't like a
control button the original like
standard mapping of this keyboard looks
like this
so you'll see that the control takes
place of the caps lock and you actually
use the function key for a lot of things
just on the far right i personally
couldn't get used to it
because i need my control lock button
mostly to change
input from japanese to english because
that's how i have it set up on my mac
and i don't really like switching my
layout too much from one keyboard to
another because i like the consistency
and so i actually remapped everything to
something that i'm comfortable with
because yes luckily you can remap all
the keys on this keyboard which is what
i would expect from a 300 keyboard
so this is what i changed my layout back
to it's very similar or it's as similar
as it can be to the mac layout
given that i don't use a control key
very much
i just kind of got rid of it and i
haven't had any problems with it really
oh on the note of customization in
addition to being able to change the key
maps for all these keys
there's also a dip switch in the back
right here
there you go and it shows you the
mappings and all the settings that you
can change
easily through these little switches the
other thing about the layout that's
different is that the backspace
is one row lower than usual a lot of
people like this because especially like
when you're coding or something
you tend to use the backspace a lot and
so you don't have to reach as far for
the backspace
typically on a keyboard this is where
you find like the backslash or like the
straight line key and stuff which in
reality
you don't use that often uh and so i
found that it's pretty nice like
it's nice that the backspace is so easy
to get to granted now i don't know where
my backslash will go
but i don't use it that often so it's
not that big of a problem
i will say though with the backspace
being here instead of here
it it's a little awkward to go back to
like a standard
keyboard layout like when i'm typing on
my mac keyboard
i'm like oh oh that's a lot further than
usual so
it does take a bit of like this context
switching but
i think this is fine that's not like
that big of a deal and the last bit on
layout in relation to usability that i
wanted to talk about
is like the unlabeled keys so i got the
unlabeled unprinted keys because i was
like it looks so clean
and so nice and it's beautiful but it
was a mistake
honestly uh i i wish i had gotten the
printed keys
so i do touch type and i can type most
of the things but really where it makes
a difference i feel like where
i struggle now is when it comes to
numbers and symbols
and if i'm typing something quickly that
i know then like it's not that big of an
issue because i'll remember where things
are
but if i'm typing like complex passwords
into something
or if i'm just typing like something
sort of not
like usual like something i don't
usually type then
it actually like i'm honestly trial and
erroring like
okay which i think the dollar sign and
pound sign is around here but i have to
kind of search for it so i actually
ordered some printed key caps
uh to put on this because it's a little
painful
but that's totally my mistake they have
a printed version
of the keycaps that they sell for hhkb
so that was just my poor judgment the
next thing i want to evaluate this thing
for usability is the battery life
so on the website it boasts like three
month battery life if you use the double
a batteries
in my experience it hasn't been that way
but all of my other friends who i talked
to
who have the hh kb have like a one to
two month battery life
so i think it's just me i think maybe
i'm just using like old batteries or
something so i'm still playing around
with it
um but it is good enough where i don't
have to like switch it out every day or
anything like that
i think right now i'm switching it out
every like three weeks but i'm pretty
sure the batteries that i have
are quite old so that's on me the one
thing i will say though is that i wish
this thing had rechargeable batteries
instead of needing to add double-a
batteries all the time
like if i could just plug in a usbc
overnight
once in a while and then this thing is
juiced that would be great it just feels
very wasteful to keep going through
double a batteries like i have a stash
of double a batteries
that this thing is using as well as my
other gadgets that use batteries
technically i could solve it by using
and buying rechargeable batteries but
it would just be easier if it had an
onboard battery itself that i can charge
so in that sense i think it loses to
something like the logitech mx keys
where you can charge the keyboard itself
also
the way that it tells you that is low
battery is a little like
not the most intuitive like an orange
dot appears where the light indicator is
and
if it's like one appears every 30
seconds and the battery is low but i'm
not gonna sit there for 30 seconds
watching this light so i wish it did
have a clearer battery indicator but
maybe that compromises on the simple
design
and the last thing in terms of usability
that i want to talk about is the
multi-device capability
so in other videos that i've talked
about for keyboards i've talked about
how important it is for me to be able to
pair
one keyboard to many devices because at
the time i was using
multiple computers and i didn't want to
have a set of keyboard
and mouse for each thing but lifestyle
change
i don't really use any other computers
other than my macbook pro these days so
i haven't had to use it
but according to my friends it's very
easy to pair and switch from one
input to another i just haven't used it
so usability wise i'll give it like six
or seven
out of ten partly because of my own user
error but also i think there are certain
things that could be done to this
keyboard to make it
even easier to use all in all this
keyboard doesn't like prevent me from
doing work or something because there
are keyboards out there that literally
like prevent me from being able to do
work on my computer
and so yeah i would say this is a very
like well
designed like usable keyboard
and the last thing that i want to talk
about for what's important to me in a
keyboard
is the delight of using one maybe i'm
turning into a bit of like a keyboard
enthusiast but i think like being
delighted by your keyboard
is kind of a nice thing like you're
gonna use it a lot
and i just like using tools whether that
be my keyboard or my mouse or my desk or
like
pens or paper or whatever that i like
using that i
enjoy using that make work and personal
life more fun
so that's another important like
requirement
for me in a keyboard and as far as the
delight goes i gotta say
this keyboard's nice i mean granted it's
like a 300
keyboard which is you know one of the
more expensive ones out there
but i feel like i've never used a
keyboard like this before
although i will say it does remind me of
like kind of retro mac
keyboard vibes probably mostly because
of the color
and the shape of the keys but i think
just like the topper switches like
how simple and light and easy it is like
the color and the look and feel of it
and stuff
you're not gonna find anything like this
out there i think one of the things that
a lot of people like about the hhkb is
the sound of the topper switches and i
also like it too i mean granted i like
the sound of most mechanical keyboards
so long as it's not too
clicky or too loud so here's a little
sound test for you for your ears for how
they sound
so in addition to sounding really good i
think it's just a very visually pleasing
keyboard it looks good on my desk on top
of my grove made mat
it matches with my logitech mouse as
well as like my macbook and my grove
main stand like it just
fits really well into like the ecosystem
of my desk
because you all know i don't like rgb
stuff i like
light colored things and when you rule
out like black colored and rgb colored
things like that's
that doesn't leave you with very many
choices when it comes to keyboards and
other things also for your desk
so i'm just happy that i found this one
so as far as delight goes
9 out of 10 because the 9 is again user
error and i don't really know what a 10
out of 10 looks like like
10 out of 10 keyboard that's delightful
like maybe it gives you snacks in the
middle of the day or something like that
like that'd be pretty cool
but you know it's a keyboard and it's
very delightful so here are the final
scores of how i view
the hhkb in terms of comfort usability
and design
i gotta say it's a good keyboard it's an
expensive keyboard but i do think that
like
for this price it's reasonable but also
i don't think it's like a necessity by
any means
so if you have like a 300 ish budget to
splurge on something to improve your
desk setup
and you're interested in using this then
i say why not i'm not sure if it's like
the best keyboard out there because best
is highly subjective
and i feel like each keyboard is good
for something different
um but i do think this is like a long
haul keyboard like i'm going to use this
for many many many years and that's
how i kind of justified the price i'm
like i'm going to use this for hours and
hours every day
for many many many years i'm going to
take good care of it
and like really enjoy using it and so it
was worth it
so that's my review on the happy hacking
keyboard let me know what you thought in
the comments down below if you have an
hhkb
tell me what you like and don't like
about it if you like this video then
make sure to give it a thumbs up
and subscribe to my channel like i said
i have other like
tool review videos and stuff and i like
making them so if there's anything that
you'd like me to review then let me know
also don't forget to subscribe and click
the bell so that you get notifications
for these videos when they come out
there'll also be a little bit of bonus
content for my youtube members and so
that'll be in the link in the
description box down below
where i further talk about my hhkb and
just
life stuff and we just talk and chill
and stuff all right everybody my hhkv
and i thank you so much for watching and
i'll see you next time
bye